es uno de los primeros países en ser
tachados de la lista de exportaciones de
moscú pero bulgaria cree firmemente que
puede prescindir del gas ruso
bulgaria no satisfará ninguna demanda
que no esté de acuerdo con el contrato y
nadie puede chantajear a bulgaria
independientemente de la posición que
crea tener mostró un grupo gary a
las autoridades afirman que el pago en
rublos exigido por rusia no forma parte
del acuerdo con gazprom que el miércoles
interrumpió las entregas a bulgaria y
polonia
vladimir putin dijo que este tipo de
exigencias se harían a países en
amistosos esto como represalia por las
sanciones impuestas a rusia y su impacto
en la economía del país
cortando los suministros de gas pero
pueden perjudicarse a sí mismos si
podemos encontrar otras fuentes
lo que ocurre a continuación dependerá
de un logo que vengan
polonia y bulgaria son miembros de la
otan de la unión europea y ahora reciben
gas de otros países miembros
y la era de los combustibles fósiles
rusos en europa está llegando a su fin
europa avanza en cuestiones energéticas
bulgaria mantuvo durante mucho tiempo
buenas relaciones con rusia pero el
gobierno que tomó posesión a finales del
año pasado condenó la invasión a ucrania
y cortó muchos de sus antiguos lazos con
moscú